all right we move on now to washington
and the still deepening case against
former president trump from the january
6 committee there is a prime time
hearing scheduled for tonight focused on
what the former president did and what
the former president did not do during
the attack we also expect to learn more
about what he did the following day
trump still no uh has accepted no
responsibility for what happened on
january 6th and he also continues to
spread lies about the last election so
let's go to scott mcfarland who is once
again on capitol hill for us scott good
morning
tony good morning to you we're expecting
to hear outtakes of a recorded speech
trump gave on january 7 2021 after his
advisors urged him to denounce the
violence but the focus of tonight's
hearing according to the committee is
what it characterizes as a failure to
act by trump for three hours as the
capital was under attack
our country has had enough the january
6th committee accuses the former
president of dereliction of duty
ignoring calls even from his inner
circle to intervene
as the riot unfolded what can you show
or tell that america hasn't seen 100
times before there's still more of the
story to tell what was the president's
response and why didn't he go a couple
feet 25 feet over to the press room and
tell folks to leave
the attack and trump's alleged inaction
spanned more than three hours
the mob flooded to the capitol at about
1 p.m with the peak of the surge and the
violence shortly after trump tweeted
criticism of mike pence after 2 p.m just
before 3 the house chamber barricaded
police guns drawn and some members
hiding beneath seats more than an hour
later and after multiple deaths only
then did trump post this twitter video
so go home
we love you you're very special tonight
the committee will hear from two top
trump white house aides who quit
immediately after the sixth former
deputy press secretary sarah matthews
and former deputy national security
adviser matthew pottinger who spoke with
face the nation shortly after january 6.
i saw the same things unfold that the
american public saw i mean images of
violence
unfolding on television and
that's when i called it quits the
committee has accused trump of being
part of a conspiracy to defraud the
united states on the eve of the prime
time hearing u.s attorney general
merrick garland didn't mention trump by
name but said no one is off limits we
have to hold comfortable
every person who is criminally
responsible for trying to overturn a
legitimate election
trump continues to deny the committee's
findings in the meantime cbs news has
confirmed the secret service shared just
one
text message from january 5th in 6 20 21
with the panel and the committee is
blasting the agency accusing them of
potentially violating federal records
law for not preserving data from those
critical days
tony
one message scott thank you very much